YouTube has demonetised our pal Steven
Crowder's Channel and declared all-out
war on conservatives this is the most
significant change in the character of
the internet since YouTube first came
online 14 years ago we will examine how
conservatives can fight back then
coincidentally one of the og
conservative youtubers Oh Rachel stops
by to discuss how social media has
changed what it looks like moving
forward
finally the mailbag I'm Michael Knowles
and this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is being called Vox ad pocalypse
because it was brought on by a Vox
journalist trying to get YouTube to
censor D platform demonetised
conservatives initially YouTube said
they wouldn't do that then they gave way
to the mob and they they have done this
to crowd or credit has almost 4 million
subscribers on YouTube this is
monumental it means none of us are safe
it means they're going to go after every
conservative channel coincidentally
right before the 2020 election we will
explain what it means what we can do
about it and why we shouldn't sit on the
sidelines and throw up our hands but
first support for the Michael Knowles
show comes from our friends at rocket
mortgage by Quicken Loans finding the
right house is not easy but finding the
right mortgage can be easy
rocket mortgage is doing more to help
you understand the home buying process
so you can get exactly what you need
because it's not just a mortgage it is
your mortgage and they have found a
better way let me tell you I look at
houses I look at this whole process I'm
a product of a millennial public
education I didn't learn any of this it
can be very difficult but luckily their
team of mortgage experts is obsessed
with finding a better way which means
that their number-one goal is to make
the home buying process smoother for you
in fact rocket mortgage is there with a
word wing client service and support
every step of the way
Quicken Loans has helped millions of
Americans achieve their dream of
homeownership and when you are ready to
purchase the home of your dreams they
can help you too when you work with them
you get more than just a loan because
rocket mortgage is more than just a
lender get started online right now
don't go into this blind don't go into
this without the best help you can get a
rocket mortgage calm /no latina wle
yes Equal Housing lender licensed in all
50 states nmls consumer access organ
number 30 30
rocket mortgage by Quicken Loans push
button get mortgage and then you have
YouTube which is push button sensor
conservatives that's how they're going
to do it
YouTube is D monetizing steven crowder
who has one of the biggest channels on
YouTube for using the words queer and
gay to refer to a gay journalist but we
here at the Michael Knowles show have an
even bigger scoop because it turns out
that there is another YouTube creator at
voxcom
who is referring to a gay journalist
with those exact same words take a
listen
straight people on TV talk about what it
would like to be gay queer people people
people people cares at all about group
people counting out their creators being
baited tours for people Allah speak
queer is not an interesting or
interesting or useful idea call me ELISA
queer is not an idea I'm a queer
tree-hugging atheist with immigrant
parents because like the feeling of
being queer in a world that doesn't love
queers as a queer person and also you
know with any queer spaces I am also an
active part of the work as a queer
person of colors to be like I mean it
was kind of like growing up queer and
and being queer and doing like queer
activism
I am literally shaking I can't believe
that YouTube would allow such a horrific
bigot on there oh excuse me I'm sorry
I'm hearing right now oh that's Carlos
maza the Vox journalist who started this
whole censorship crusade in the first
place by the way oh that clip could go
on about seven or eight minutes longer
there is an endless supply of Carlos
Mazda using the word queer gay all of
these different words to refer to
himself so when Carlos maza from voxcom
a left-wing website uses exactly the
same words that steven crowder used it's
okay that's fine that's great when
steven crowder uses those exact same
words he gets demonetised he is told by
YouTube you can't make any money on here
because you have opinions that we don't
like when is YouTube going to D monetize
vox.com for using the exact
words that steven crowder used I'm not
kidding I'm not just trying to make a
point I think YouTube should D monetize
voxcom
I think YouTube should D platform Carlos
maza because he's using those exact same
words I'm not making an absurd argument
here YouTube is enforcing some brand new
policy that they just wrote yesterday in
response to Carlos Massa and voxcom
calling for Crowder to be deep
platformed and demonetised they are
enforcing that on Crowder they have to
enforce that on voxcom
in fact they should enforce it on
everybody who makes any gay joke who
makes who uses the word gay who uses the
word queer any of them on YouTube by the
way YouTube uses the word queer because
YouTube is now promoting Pride Month and
a month to celebrate LGBTQ guess what
the Q stands for stands for queer they
all need to be D platforms their
channels need to be deleted they at
least need to be D monetized until
voxcom is d monetized YouTube is taking
an obvious bigoted swipe at
conservatives why is it OK
when Vox uses certain words but when but
not okay when Crowder does Washington
Post showed this just yesterday
Washington Post put out an article about
this whole controversy and they wrote
when they when they described Carlos
Mazda they said he is quote a video
producer for the new site Vox and they
described him as a quote gay and Latino
then two paragraphs later in the article
they criticized steven crowder for
referring to maza as a gay latino from
vox so Washington Post says he's a video
producer from the new site Vox and he is
gay and Latino then Crowder calls him a
gay Latino from Vox that's hateful two
paragraphs later what is actually
happening here YouTube has decided to
punish the creators that it doesn't like
with D monetization when you post a
video to YouTube you can turn on
monetization and then when you get half
a million people to watch it they'll run
ads on that video and you can make some
money and that's how YouTube creators
sustain themselves online now they're
going to demonetised them and they're
already saying that they're going to
deep platform thousands of
creators that they don't like YouTube is
punishing people not who violate the
rules but who they just don't like I'm
not exaggerating here YouTube concluded
that steven crowder did not violate
their rules they admitted that in a
statement then once they got more
pressure from voxcom journalists
journalists quote-unquote who are trying
to censor everybody else from speaking
when they gave in to the pressure they
said alright Crider didn't violate the
rules but we're going to demonetised him
anyway this is their Orwellian statement
quote even if a creators content doesn't
violate our Community Guidelines
we will take a look at the broader
context and impact and if their behavior
is egregious and harms the broader
community we may take action they said
in the case of Crowder's channel a
thorough review over the weekend found
that individually the flagged videos did
not violate our Community Guidelines
however in the subsequent days we saw
the widespread harm to the YouTube
community and listen to that you see
what they're doing there once again as
the left always does conflating speech
with violence they say look we have
rules against threatening speech speech
that actually could incite violence that
is being used to threaten violence we
have rules against that creditor didn't
violate those rules but in the broad
context of his speech it's harmful to
the YouTube community quote resulting
from the ongoing pattern of egregious
behavior took a detour deeper look and
made the decision to suspend
monetization in order to be considered
for reinstatement all relevant issues
with the channel need to be addressed
including any videos that violate our
policies as well as things like if
offensive merchandise and their what
they were alluding to is is he has a
shirt which is che guevara with a limp
wrist and it says socialism is for FIGS
then instead of a letter there between
the F and the G it's a little fig
coincidentally che guevara was killed in
a town called Higuera
which means the fig tree just a little
extra information on that YouTube is
promising that they will write the rules
arbitrarily because they had rules when
they instituted the rules they say
you're here the rules don't violate them
we won't kick you off Grider doesn't
violate them
they say we're gonna kick you off anyway
we're gonna demolish you at least anyway
so it's it's just YouTube picking
winners and losers based on the content
based on the opinions based on the
ideology of the creators that are going
out there how are they going to do this
YouTube is now promising that it will be
quote removing violative content content
that violates their agreement they
already were doing that raising up a
thorat ativ content okay and let's see
what that authoritative content is
reducing the spread of borderline
content so content that doesn't violate
their rules but they don't like it
anyway and rewarding trusted creators I
wonder who those trusted creators are I
mean I seem to recall that the Young
Turks a very far left-wing channel would
film their shows in YouTube's
headquarters in the YouTube studios I
guess their trusted the very far left
wing sources are trusted I don't film in
YouTube's headquarters do i steven
crowder doesn't film in youtube so i
guess we're not trusted and they're
gonna raise up a Thorat ativ content
what is the thorah tative content is
authoritative content the New York Times
New York Times has botched huge high
profile stories over the last three
years
CNN watched huge high profile stories is
it those guys something tells me
authoritative content isn't the Daily
wire but then how are they going to
boost that authoritative content they
write this is YouTube writing quote if a
user is watching a video that comes
close to violating our policies our
systems may include more videos from
authoritative sources like top news
channels in the watch next panel so
let's say that you decide that you're
gonna watch the Michael Knowles show
heaven forfend and you're watching and
you're listening to ideas that are a
little more conservative what YouTube
will do then is is after that when you
look at the watch next channel all the
videos that are suggested next to the
page at the end on the screen you're
gonna get the New York Times you're
gonna get CNN you're gonna get the Young
Turks filmed in YouTube studios you're
gonna get all this left-wing content
what is this about what's the takeaway
it's a two-fold political stunt why did
Carlos Mazda do this now he said he said
the crowd has been calling him a list
be queer for years Maz has been calling
himself a queer for years why right now
what's because this is Pride Month
Carlos Mazda launched this whole crusade
on May 30th two days before the launch
of Pride Month
this was not an exasperated emotional
reaction to harassment this was a highly
calculated premeditated attempt to
censor conservatives on YouTube and
other social media which are by the way
the largest public squares in the entire
world certainly in the country but in
the entire world as well this was a
highly calculated attempt by a highly
calculating political operative named
Carlos masa
to censor conservatives from the public
square and it has mostly worked by the
way good I mean you got it he's a whiny
on American authoritarian but Carlos
maza is pretty effective but it's not
just launched at the beginning of Pride
Month it's launched at the beginning of
the 2020 cycle its 2019 the elections
are underway and now the YouTube is
going to mobilize to help Democrats
unfairly you know the left complaints
about citizens united have that next
Supreme Court decision upheld the
corporation's right to donate to
political campaigns they said it was
awful they said corporations aren't
people corporations can't donate what is
this what this is is just one giant
completely unregulated corporate
donation to Democrats they're admitting
it they say they're going to censor
conservatives and they're going to help
Democrats at least after citizens united
other corporations have to disclose
their political contributions not
YouTube YouTube doesn't have to disclose
this it's a huge in-kind contribution
for Dems during a very contentious
election year so how should
conservatives respond this this reopens
the same debate between conservatism and
classical liberalism conservative
liberalism or whatever that we have been
talking about for the past two weeks
some libertarian classical liberal types
insists that the government should take
no action they say YouTube is a private
company they can kick off whoever they
want it's not the government no big deal
that's one idea they're uncomfortable
with the government stepping in to
regulate social media now the less
classical liberal more conservative
minded people say
absolutely the government should prevent
this mass censorship on a national and
global scale of conservative ideas so
which is it should we say hands off
YouTube can do whatever they want or
should we get involved this is based on
a faulty premise this is based on the
premise that the government right now
doesn't already have its finger on the
scales it does the government is already
giving these corporations like YouTube
and unfair protection the law in this
country is supposed to treat publishers
and platforms differently right now
however the law is treating social media
companies like publishers when it suits
them and like publishers and like
platforms rather when it when it suits
them otherwise in some cases it's won in
some cases it's the other this is not
exactly on the question of censorship
it's on the question of what these
companies are so the Daily wire we have
no obligation to publish views that we
disagree with we do because all of the
writers and the hosts we all disagree
with each other all the time but we
don't publish every single opinion in
the world we're not a left-wing news
site we're a conservative news site we
don't need to worry about charges of
censorship because we're a publisher we
decide what we want to publish we pick
which stories to run but since we're a
publisher we have to worry about a lot
of other things copyright infringement
defamation libel IP theft fair use all
these different things that YouTube
Facebook and Twitter or all the other
social media companies don't have to
worry about because they say that they
are they are platforms and not
publishers sometimes they say they're
just an internet platform which gives
them a whole lot of government help a
whole lot of protections section 230 of
the Communications Decency Act of 1996
says no provider or user of an
interactive computer service shall be
treated as a publisher or speaker of any
information provided by another
information content provider what's the
purpose of that it's so that the
internet could grow and this has led to
incredible growth by protecting tech
companies from copyright and other
publisher issues it allowed them not to
get totally bogged down and stifled as
the internet was growing it's created
billionaires it's created billion-dollar
corporations it has allowed the internet
to flourish
now those published those platforms
rather or a be using that protection the
protection that was made to allow the
internet to grow to allow these
companies to exist they are now abusing
that protection and behaving as
publishers obviously they're choosing
what content they want on the platform
what content they don't not just YouTube
it's all of big tech trying to have it
both ways here is Mark Zuckerberg trying
to say on the one hand he's a he's a CEO
of a social media platform you said you
are responsible for your content so
which are you are you a tech company are
you the world's largest publisher
because I think that goes to a really
important question on what form of
regulation or government action if any
we would take senator this is a really
big question I I view us as a tech
company because the primary thing that
we do is build technology and cloud
you're responsible for your content
which make exactly line of a publisher
right well I agree that we're
responsible for the content but we don't
produce the content I think that when
people ask us if we're a media company
or a publisher my understanding of what
the heart of what they're really getting
at is do we feel a responsibility for
the content on our platform the answer
to that I think is clearly yes and but I
don't think that that's incompatible
with fundamentally yet at our core being
a technology company were the main thing
that we do is have engineers and build
products right ok so he's saying we are
primarily an open platform however while
they were fighting a lawsuit in
California last July Facebook claimed
that they were a publisher Facebook was
being sued by a tech startup that was
told they were developing apps with
Facebook and the premise was they would
be able to use the data from Facebook to
develop the apps then Facebook pulled
the data from the apps and they sued
them the lawyer for Facebook sonal Mehta
said quote the publisher discretion is a
free speech right irrespective of what
technological means is used a newspaper
has a publisher function when they are
doing it on their website in a printed
copy or through news alerts so he said
they're a they're a publisher
he then said that decisions about data
were a quote quintessential publisher
function and constituted protective
activity adding that this quote includes
both the decision of what to publish and
the decision of what not to publish so
Facebook is a publisher when it suits
them right they are they these tech
companies are behaving as publishers and
the data are important here because the
data show you how powerful these
companies have become they know
everything about you they there are no
competitors to them they control the
flow of information on the Internet
there is this debate on the right and
we'll bring xoan and have this debate
some of the liberal libertarian school
say who cares have powerful big tech
gets who cares have they censor who
cares have a mold discourse and and
block conservatives from the public
square just so long as they're not the
government that's one school of thought
that is no consolation to me I don't
care that they're not the government I
don't care if I'm being censored but in
my politics is being cheated by by
government by just a giant government
entity or by a handful of the biggest
companies on earth who are getting
special protections from the government
I don't care it needs to end we need to
stop the special protection for big tech
and conservatives need to grow a spine
and say that we need to have it launched
an all on legal assault on these
companies this is a an unfair advantage
that they are giving to Democrats in
2020
this is censoring the public square this
is abusing their power this is abusing
the law and this is and frankly it's
illegal what they're doing we should
take the Vox ad pocalypse as a great
opportunity to to say enough is enough
this has been creeping censorship for a
long time and it's over this also
reminds us why we need to go over to
Daily wire calm you know I mean this is
the big issue of the day if you care
about free speech and diversity of
thought go to Daley wire calm right now
Daley we're calm /youtube and add your
name to the list of people standing up
against the bullies at YouTube and
speaking out for free speech it's very
important daily wire calm /youtube join
the fight with us
we're gonna bring on one of the og
conservative youtubers so Rachel luckily
coincidentally was coming by the studio
today
if you don't remember as oh this is back
this video is from ten years ago in the
old days when social media really were
the Wild West it's got half a million
views on YouTube
back when YouTube wasn't censoring
conservatives this is so Rachel okay so
the question is why am i a Republican as
a conservative Republican I believe that
war sucks all but their bases suck way
worse than war y'all slavery genocide
tyranny peace through strength y'all I'm
a conservative Republican because I'm
pro-life I'm a conservative Republican
because I believe that marriage should
be between a man and a woman as a
conservative Republican I support the
Second Amendment as a conservative
Republican I appreciate what America is
as a conservative Republican and I
believe in a maximum of a 10 percent
consumption tax as a conservative
Republican I think we're smart enough to
earn the money then we're smart enough
to know how to spend it I'm a
conservative Republican because I
believe the abstinence should be taught
in school instead of having free condoms
in the office as a conservative
Republican I'm proud of my country I'm
proud that our country is seen as the
place that if you want the best chance
to realize your dream it's the place
that come to man I don't think we're
better than anybody else it's America we
are everybody else I could go on y'all
but I'm just gonna say that I'm a
conservative Republican because I
believe in God and we're joined now by
so Rachel what's goin on man you look
exactly the same
well thank you can't even see the
difference ten years and nothing has
changed at all that's well I appreciate
that this was such a lucky day in such a
coincidental day for you to be walking
by the studios nice well is it because
it's Gay Pride Month no not because it's
Gay Pride Month because YouTube is in
the news and you were one of the og
conservative youtubers I mean ten years
ago you're talking about 2009 yeah that
video came out what changed between the
old days when you could get half a
million views on just a here's my
opinion on conservative politics - now
when steven crowder uses the word queer
mmm the same word that is in LGBTQ right
and he gets a demonetised in the
threatening 2d platformer him what
changed Oh how long do I have
go on for days a minute yeah we could we
could end it because it's been going on
for years
and man I would say you know I don't
want to say I told you so
but I've been trying to let folks know
that man you know as conservatives we
got to be careful not to underestimate
liberals their worldview may be foolish
but they're not exactly stupid people
and they've created the platforms that
conservatives have been dependent on to
get their message out and I've said for
a long time and it's like you know these
Silicon Valley liberals ain't gonna sit
there and let us talk about you know
their worldview the way to be doing them
before they pull the rug up from
underneath us uh we we're gonna have to
come up with some sort of a viable
competitor and I don't mean like some
sort of like conservative platform or
something like that you know you know
hey this is the right thing is no it's
it's gonna have to be something that's
just as interesting you know the content
in a way that it's uh organized and all
that sort of stuff you know I can't be
the guy to do it I'm not that tech savvy
you know artists you know but anyway
these people how this how this came
about is basically you know they created
this stuff and we just can't use their
stuff and do what we're doing right we
must have been crazy to think that we
could get away with us airing our views
and destroying their stupid ideas for
tenure eventually they're going to get
sick of it I remember in the early days
of YouTube right around the time you
made that video I was working on a
Republican campaign in New York and
nobody was using social media so we used
it in all these sorts of new ways we
were doing music videos to attack the
other guy we were and they were catching
a lot of traction and you could do that
back then the Conservatives thought
social media are here finally the
monopoly of the mainstream media is
broken with you had PJTV early on which
you were at I mean all obviously daily
YRC our team all of these different
companies blew up and now they are
totally attacking us there they're
getting the rug out from under us and
and we've been what's been part of our
content is letting folks know that
Democrats is crazy you know it's this
isn't a new thing like you know we talk
about the
becoming unhinged and uh you know and
they're and they're going crazy and been
crazy you know these are people who blow
up churches you know these are people
who have lynch mobs these are people
where we have you know what that's
illegal you guys can't keep doing that
you know so we had to make you know
anti-lynching laws these people have
been crazy so you know at this point
it's like you know you know we might
need to take that in and get out of
crazy folks backyard right and create
our own thing like you guys are doing
right now how does this end though I
mean does this end with conservatives
they just shut us up and we've got to
wait for some new technology to develop
or does this actually energize
conservatives as we look at 2020 well I
hope that it would intercept it would
energize conservatives and and use the
formula that's always been under our
nose we see how liberals have been able
to do it music movies education sent up
there they're there in everything and
we're conservatives usually aren't and
the thing is we're as conservatives we
tend to think that people I think I
think we get booked people a lot have
benefited out that we can reason with
them you know we're going to go and we
have this this solid reasoning that
people are gonna understand and every
once in a while you made make a
connection I was a liberal you know and
I figure it but knucklehead like me can
get it anybody can get it but reason is
just out of language that they
understand and I'm not being literal
here it's just something that they
really don't get their world is
imagination that's why all the stuff
that they believe is filtered through it
and imagination their information their
education all that sort of stuff is
imagination land and that's just an area
that conservatives are don't tap you
know it's all the narrative right they
they construct a narrative even if it's
false if everyone sticks to the
narrative then they get to do what they
want and you know like me your Hollywood
conservative you were in the Gosnell
movie you've got a new album out I mean
you've been working around show business
for a long time conservatives don't want
anything to do with your business well I
don't know man because you know Netflix
is getting that money from somewhere
let's not pretend the Conservatives
don't have a Netflix account they so we
you know we really stole somebody's
password to log in to Netflix to watch
the shows yeah right get them hacks
going man you know Netflix HBO you know
all that sort of stuff we're wondering
you know how our liberals say
because we're funding them to do it and
you know it's it's about time that the
the supply and demand party starts
applying in demanding interesting ways
to promote our ideas because that's what
you got to do should the government go
in and either regulate these big social
media companies or enforce the existing
law or do you think hands off will just
make our own platform oh man okay of you
know the government getting involved too
to make this kind of regulation I my
instinct is no riots the conservative
instinct is I don't want the government
to touch it everything it touches turns
to dust mm-hmm in the case of YouTube
maybe it should turn to dust that's
another discussion however you know when
you do have an entity that is
interfering you know that the scope that
they're doing interfering with people's
lives their livelihood tapping into and
this opens up another discussion about
privacy you know people would say that
privacy well it's not in the
Constitution I would argue yes it is and
they are violating our right to privacy
because your privacy is your property
and we do have a constitutional rights
of property so and they're infringing
upon that um they're infinite on our
right to pursue happiness by do anything
our life is oh my contention with that
though is that what we volunteered for
it we don't have like any sort of
monetary covenant with them or anything
like that we're we're we gave them the
data we gave it to them my only issue is
they pretend to be platforms when it
suits them then they say that their
publishers when they're actually in
their own behavior and they I don't
think they should be able to get it both
ways you know I don't think we should I
think we if I don't know that we should
go in and write new laws and write new
regulations we certainly should enforce
laws that we already have one yeah yeah
this if I actually think this helps us
in 2020 I think this helps I think
Republicans and conservatives do best
when it's so clear that the pop culture
is stacked against us that the
mainstream media is stacked against us
and Donald Trump does very well when
he's gotten an adversary and
I think this is totally gonna backfire
on them what about you I I hope so I I
like to go along with that thinking um
you know I get discouraged when I think
about the hangman we lost the Congress
you know got to be careful with with how
we may hope things go away right but but
Donald Trump if we could use him as a
model you know how is he successful
because he had that pop culture
connection right you know he took his
whole campaign and brought it into his
reality TV show wheelhouse and these are
things that conservatives like look I
understand conservatives to make up a
conservative there's a formula yeah just
the same way there's a formative make up
liberal liberals are imaginative people
conservatives are practical people you
know in conservatives you know what
we're doing what they're doing because
they have this practical nature it
doesn't lend a lot to creativity well
that's what conservatives have to say
well you know what maybe we need to find
the people who are and support them that
way we can have a means to promote our
narrative in a way that captures people
attention long enough to tell them the
truth
you're an imaginative conservative where
can people go and support you well thank
you uh at bronze serpent Mediacom they
can catch my book a solid right cross
they can catch them throughout my my
band 20-pound sledge best man you never
heard of no about my only issue with the
new book sounds great but one of my
favorite titles for any book of all time
is the name of your first book we and
that was that was strategically planned
weapon of a SS destruction and you know
III titled that you know because a SS
stands for American socialist States
right seems work we're trying to be
jacked but I figured you know what I
think maybe people looking for gay porn
might look up this book so big I mean
that's like half the internet ID right
and they might either be very
enlightened or very disappointed so well
it's great I'm sure that after the new
book is a great read to but so great to
see you man always great for you to come
by come by more often all right man all
right we've got to say goodbye to
Facebook and YouTube
we're probably gonna say goodbye to them
forever pretty soon go over to Daley
wired.com now more than ever seriously
guys join us in the fight against big
tech censorship YouTube has demonetised
Stephen Crowder's Channel they are not
going to stop there if you care about
free speech and diversity of thought
then head
/ - daily wire.com /youtube and add your
name to the list of people standing up
against the bullies at YouTube and
speaking out for free speech this is
very important
daily wired.com /youtube join the fight
and show big tech that we're not going
to take it anymore ten bucks a month
hundred dollars for an annual membership
you get me the Andrew Clavin show ben
shapiro show the met wall show you can
test questions in the mailbag which is
coming right up you get another kingdom
you get all of this you get the leftist
tiers tumblr which i think is going to
be very important because they won the
battle today i don't think they're gonna
win the war i think this is going to
energize conservatives in 2020 and i I
think I've I haven't felt more
invigorated to fight big tech censorship
ever in my life this is a major turning
point go over get the leftist ears
tumblr before you drown we'll be right
back
let's get to the mailbag with what
little time we have left first question
from Nicole as Pride Month starts
including all kinds of sexualities and
genders I wonder if heterosexuality will
ever be included
I believe leaving them out creates a
narrative of conflict between
heterosexuals and everyone else which is
completely unproductive and I'd love to
know your thoughts Thanks it does create
a conflict and a division that's the
whole point of course it used to be gay
pride so if you were gay as opposed to
straight you would go out and march in
the Pride Parade then it became gay and
lesbian pride gay lesbian bisexual pride
now that adds transgender it adds queer
I'm probably gonna get banned from
YouTube for saying that it adds IA I
don't know what those stand for the
acronym gets longer by the minute but it
will never include straight people it
can't the whole purpose of of the the
Pride movement or of all of the other
left-wing political movements is to
create an enemy and then to create
solidarity among everyone who isn't the
enemy so in this case the the mean awful
terrible oppressors are the straight
people and then everyone who isn't
straight is in solidarity with each
other gay lesbian transgender I mean
it's it's really strange that gay and
transgender go together
the premise of homosexuality is that if
boys who like boys and girls who like
girls people who are attracted to the
same sex
the premise of transgenderism is that
there's really no such thing as sex that
sexes is totally changeable that it's a
social construct you can move fluidly
from one to the other
those are antithetical concepts but they
they have come together to fight the
oppressor this is the idea of the 99%
versus the 1% it's a pretty brilliant
political strategy of course a mob of
99% of people is always going to
overpower 1% it's it's the leftist
strategy of division of finding a
scapegoat of targeting them of censoring
them of shutting them up even if the
interests of all the other groups don't
quite
so now they're not going to add straight
people to the parade although they're in
Boston there's going to be a straight
Pride Parade apparently with floats and
people try to head over there and see
what it's like from Paul any other and
other than technology what is the
difference between spying on the GOP
campaign in 2016 president Trump and
Watergate there's a big difference
between the Obama administration's
spying on the Trump campaign which we
now know for a fact happened we don't
know for a fact that it was improper but
we know for a fact that it happened big
difference between Obama's
administration's spying on the Trump
campaign and Watergate when Richard
Nixon's re-election campaign spied on
the Democrats the big difference is
Richard Nixon didn't use the force of
the state to spy on the Democrats
he hired his own goons through the
campaign and they totally bungled
burglary at the Watergate building DNC
headquarters and they got caught the
Obama administration used the full power
of the American intelligence community
to spy on a rival presidential campaign
that's not a conspiracy theory we know
that happened the question now is
whether that that spying was adequately
predicated whether it was appropriate or
whether it was inappropriate hopefully
we'll get answers to that now that
attorney general bar has a US attorney
working on the case and we're waiting
for the inspector general's report as
well but if the spying on the Trump
campaign was not was not appropriately
predicated it is so much worse than
Watergate it's barely comparable from
Nicole a pro-choice er on Twitter made
the argument that medically speaking an
abortion is more of an induced
miscarriage than murder which is most
medically accurate a good question it's
true that an abortion is an induced
miscarriage the the instrument of the
murder is the induced miscarriage it
would be like saying that if I walked up
to you on the street and slit your
throat that's not really murder
it's an
deuced hemorrhage you died from an
induced hemorrhage it's true it was
induced it was induced by whom by me
when I committed that act what did I do
I committed murder of course it what
what they're confusing is physical
descriptions and the act itself I can
cut your throat and have it be an
induced hemorrhage I still committed
murder I can induce a miscarriage in a
baby that's committing murder and I
won't get into the gory details but when
you look at how abortions are actually
carried out it is even visually
indistinguishable for murder from Patti
regarding abortion I have several
friends that argue that when you see
crack babies and abused and neglected
children that an abortion would be
preferable to all that suffering I know
it's wrong but I can't come up with any
good analogy that would be comparable
and make the issue crystal clear that
argument seems the only one with merit
can you help me out with this sure I
live in Los Angeles
I see miserable people all the time
people who are suffering people who are
miserable people who didn't get that
audition that they really wanted to get
people who are completely lost wandering
the streets of LA so can I kill them
because I think it's better I just think
it would be better for them to be dead
then for them to be living in the
squalor and misery and suffering that
they're living in in Los Angeles so can
I kill them no of course not why because
I would still be killing them it would
still be murder but also and a more
important level the purpose of life is
not to avoid suffering everybody suffers
it's not just crack babies who suffer
it's not just neglected children who
suffer everybody suffers suffering is a
feature not a bug of life we all do it
now what sort of suffering justifies
killing yourself obviously nothing for
any of the people that we're talking to
because none of the people we're talking
to have killed themselves we have a
bizarre fascination and and incorrect
idea in the society that suffering
is a justification for ending life that
the chief purpose of life is to feel
happy all the time
that isn't true it if suffering
justified ending life we would all kill
ourselves and so you you have to find a
better argument I guess the argument
that they're making is my suffering
doesn't justify taking my life but
they're suffering justifies me taking
their life it's a totally incoherent
point tell them to go back to the
drawing board and start again from Garon
hi Michael despite Ben's best efforts to
thwart his viewers from listening to
your terrible show I'm a major fan of
the execrable Michael Knowles hashtag
came for Ben stayed for Michael thank
you very much I noticed that Democrats
attempt to undermine Republican
achievements such as ending slavery they
will say things like the Democrats and
the Republicans switched platforms what
is your take on this sincerely
Garren I don't know what's my take on
Bigfoot what's my take on the abominable
snowman it's just completely ridiculous
to say that the Democrats and the
Republicans switched platforms well how
do you think that happened do you think
one day just around the time that all of
the prominent Democrats who are around
today happened to come of age in
politics the Democrats and the
Republicans mr. Democrat mr. Republican
sat down at a table and said okay so now
for no reason whatsoever you mr.
Democrat are gonna start being mr.
Republican and I mr. Republican I'm
going to start being mr. Democrat why
are we going to do this I have
absolutely no idea how is it possible to
get two parties to completely switch I
can't even imagine but we're going to do
it because a bunch of boomer Democrats
in the 90s and 2000 said it was true
that's the that's the argument it
doesn't make any sense it is true that
the parties change over time but it
isn't because they just switched parties
one day the Republican Party was founded
to end slavery because the Republican
Party has had a fascination with
american-style Liberty from the very
beginning and it continues to to this
day now during the 20th century of
geographically you saw a beginning of a
change in political alignments so what
the Democrats want you to believe is
that we
over the issue of civil rights and
because of the Civil Rights Act in the
1960s black Republicans became Democrats
that isn't true the move of black
Americans from the Democrat to the
Republican Party began decades earlier
it began during Franklin Delano
Roosevelt in the New Deal and it also
coincided with a shift as they moved
from the south up to the north the align
realignment of certain southern states
coincided not with the Civil Rights Act
but actually happened decades later it
really only solidified in the late 80s
and 1990s why is that it's because the
Democrat Party moved staunchly to the
left they they moved radically to the
left and they abandoned a lot of the
cultural conservative ideas that all
Americans used to share they boo God at
their National Convention in 2008 2008
or 2012 they become highly secular they
become radically pro-abortion they
embrace gay marriage as an idea so
they're taking on all of these radical
leftist ideas they go soft on communism
there used to be anti-communist
Democrats that has really ceased to
exist anymore as Democrats have embraced
socialism so a lot of cultural reasons
why certain areas moved more to the
right or moved more to embrace the
Republican Party but they didn't switch
I mean the reason the Democrats want to
take credit for all the Republican
achievements is because the Democrat
Party is is one of the worst political
forces in the history of the world it is
just a 200 year record of untold mayhem
and destruction and immorality so
they're trying to take credit for
Republican achievements but sorry ain't
gonna work from Michael hey Michael it's
Michael hey Michael I'm a graduating
senior I'm making a turn in my life and
I want to go into politics any
suggestions on where to start yes turn
away and go do something else
there's no depends what you mean by
politics working on a political campaign
is some of the best training you can get
in your life for anything because you
get paid peanuts you work 18 hours a day
you are interacting with people all the
time strangers and new people really
getting to understand human nature
really getting to understand people if
you don't like people it will chase you
away from it because you're always
interacting with strangers and if you do
like people it will deepen your love of
people because you see that everyone is
different you can celebrate their
diversity their foibles what makes them
tick what what motivates them so I think
working on campaigns is great if you
want to start just spouting your
political opinions all the time like I
do I would wait at least a few years and
go do some other things get some life
experience before you start that at the
tender age of 22 if you want to run for
office don't do it don't run it 22 you
just haven't lived enough to run and be
a serious candidate if you want to work
as an a Hill staffer or somebody for a
an elected official I think that's
pretty good training too you won't make
a whole lot of money but it'll teach you
a lot and if you aspire to be in high
office someday maybe a route for you to
do is go and make some money go work in
business go have a regular career then
start running when you're 35 or 40 and
you'll you'll bring something more to
the table from Eric last question oh hi
Michael
did you know Alexander Graham Bell
proposed to answering the telephone with
ahoy I didn't know that but now I do
happy belated Anniversary to you and
sweet little Alisa my question is about
movies whenever drew has you review a
movie it's typically something drew has
made you watch meaning that we get to
hear about how awful it is
Avengers end game sorry to bother you
that Anita Hill movie on HBO for example
are there any movies besides The
Godfather in The Godfather Part 2 that
you really like yes there are many on
the waterfront streetcar named desire I
don't know I don't know I loved all is
lost that Robert Redford movie I loved
Hail Caesar
those are more recent movies but perhaps
my favorite movie is one of the most
underappreciated films ever made
starring a complete lunatic leftist
wacko but nonetheless it's one of the
greatest movies ever made and that movie
is me myself and Irene by the Farrelly
Brothers it's a true masterpiece I could
watch it endlessly enjoy the weekend go
watch me myself and Irene we'll see you
on Monday in the meantime I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy Borah
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is
mixed by Dylan case hair and makeup is
by Jeshua alvera and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19 hey everyone
its Andrew Klavan host of the Andrew
Klavan show d-day was 75 years ago today
and for all the sentimental remembrances
and heartfelt tributes it's virtually
impossible to recapture or convey the
scale and scope of the heroism and
sacrifice that was required to begin the
rollback of the Nazi conquest you have
to ask yourself could we do it today
would we why did they fight why did they
win and have we lost what it takes to
pull off that kind of monumental triumph
we'll talk about it on the Andrew Klavan
show I'm Andrew Clavin